كما علمتنا ، هذا نموذج
لما نحن عليه
الآن إذا اتبعنا هذا المسار
بنفس نقاط البيانات ،
فهذا ما سيحدث في
ديسمبر
3000 حالة وفاة يوميًا ، حسنًا ، هذا مستوى 11 11
من الخسارة ، حسنًا ، من
المستحيل تخيل  مجرد الصدمة اليومية
لنظامنا ،
حسنًا من ذلك ، لكننا لسنا مجرد
بطة
كما تعلمون بهذه الطريقة ، أعني
أن لدينا بعض
القوة الآن لخفض هذه الأرقام بشكل
صحيح ، أعني أنهم نظروا أيضًا إلى
ما  ستنظر الأرقام في ما إذا كان
هناك معدل متوافق بنسبة 95 في المائة ،
لذلك إذا كان 95
من البلاد يرتدون أقنعة ، ما
ستبدو عليه أرقامنا ،
نعم أعني ، وبالتالي ستتحسن أرقامنا بشكل
كبير
إذا كان لدينا نوعًا من القناع الشامل الذي
يرتدي بشكل صحيح بدلاً من ذلك  من بين
410.000 شخص يموتون ، سيكون هذا أقرب
إلى
288000. لذا فأنت تعلم أنه من
المثير للاهتمام على الرغم من كيف يمكنك
النظر إلى تلك الأرقام التي تعرفها؟
كان
علي أن أخبرك رغم أنه بعد
شهور عديدة من الإبلاغ عن هذا
الأمر ما زال صادمًا بالنسبة لي
أن هذا هو أفضل ما يمكننا
فعله الآن هو أن مائة
ألف شخص لا يزالون سيموتون حتى لو قلنا
في هذه المرحلة أننا  سوف يتراجعون
تمامًا ويفعلون الأشياء الصحيحة ، ولا توجد طريقة
للقيام بذلك ،
أعني أنك تعرف أنني لا أعرف ما الذي
يتطلبه الأمر في هذه المرحلة
لأقول في الواقع ، انظر ، يمكنك أن تكون
جزءًا من حركة
يمكن أن تنقذ  أكثر من مائة
ألف كذبة إذا قمت ببساطة بوضع حلقتي أذن
حول
أذنيك ويمكنك المساعدة في إنقاذ
حياة جيرانك ، حياة مجتمعاتك ،
أناس لا تعرفهم حتى ،
ويقول الناس أنك تعرف ما الذي أفسده ،
لا أفضّل ذلك.  ماذا أين
نحن أعني أنك تعرف أن الناس قالوا في
البداية أن هذا ليس تهديدًا وجوديًا
وأنهم يشيرون إلى
الفيروس الذي أعتقد أنه لا يزال صحيحًا
لأنه من الواضح أن هناك أماكن
حول العالم تمكنت من التحكم في
هذا
الأمر  لقد بدأت أشعر أن
التهديد الوجودي هو السلوك البشري ،
أعني أنني أشعر بالإحباط
والإحباط لأنني أعني أنني أكره أن
يستيقظ الناس على ذلك الصباح ولكن
ما الذي نفعله هنا في  هذه
النقطة يحبها الجميع.
يجب
أن يتوقف عن فعل كل الأشياء التي
نعرف أنها
ستنجح ، يتم تطعيم البلدان الأخرى بشكل
أساسي في الوقت الحالي
ليس لأن لديهم لقاحًا
ولكن لأنهم فعلوا هذه الأشياء ،
فقد عادوا إلى طبيعتهم كما هم ،
لقد خفضوا معدلات وفياتهم
في العشرات أو المئات
وليس مئات الآلاف ،
أعتقد أننا حقًا لدينا حساب
فيما يتعلق فقط بالآداب الإنسانية الأساسية
في هذا البلد في هذه المرحلة